this is sadly our last night at
comic-con yeah I'm not looking for the
journey home cuz I'm going back to LA on
a bird scooter you notice that they do
that sure yeah it's our last night we've
done up four shows less dumb in four
shows yes yeah and if you've seen The
Fast and the Furious movies you know
four is plenty so actually two is plenty
I gotta say I'm a little worried people
are getting really drunk down here at
Cana pie I hate to say it I think many
of them are making poor decisions many
of you I do last night the Green Lantern
got so drunk he agreed to do another
movie
[Applause]
oh so kinda right over there looking sad
rubbing his green ring of course there's
some nice stories this is true a group
of friends cosplaying the Black Panther
drove here all the way from Georgia yeah
hey even more impressive a group of
friends cause playing The Handmaid's
Tale drove all the way from Mike Pence's
house
today at comic-con there was a panel on
how graphic novels can help with
bullying yeah if you if you weren't able
to make it to the panel let me summarize
they can't
it's [ __ ] I'm gonna bully wait a
minute huh oh yeah at Comic Con you can
try out a new virtual reality game
that's based on The Walking Dead heard
about this it's cool yeah yeah the the
VR lets you feel what it's like to be a
zombie or if you're from Los Angeles
what it's like to walk so
Oh
you